Ladies and gentlemen, our program is about to begin.
Good afternoon.
My name is Max Diehn. I'm a professor at Stanford University in the
Stanford Cancer Institute, and it's my distinct honor to
serve as chair for this afternoon's Discovery Science
Plenary titled "The Next Frontier in Minimal Residual Disease:
Solid Tumors."
Here are my disclosures.
The topic of this session will be minimal residual disease.
Minimal residual disease refers to low levels of tumor burden remaining
after treatment in cancer patients.
Now, MRD has been used to personalize treatment in hematologic
malignancies for decades and has been very effective there to both escalate and
deescalate therapy.
However, until recently, there have not been sufficient advances
to allow similar strategies to be applied in patients with solid tumors.
However, over the last few years, MRD in solid tumors has become
a growing area of interest due to advances both in understanding of biology
of MRD, as well as techniques to detect it in
patients.
Now, to frame this session, I want to make an important
distinction between two types of MRD in solid tumors.
It's important to recognize that there's really two different subsets of
MRD we're talking about. The first is MRD after systemic
therapy. This mainly occurs in patients with advanced disease who are
treated with systemic therapy, have a deep response,
and then have either no radiographic disease or still some
small amounts of radiographic disease, both of which contain residual
tumor cells. Now the biologic cause of this type of MRD is
persister cells that are resistant to the prior line of therapy.
Because of that, it's in a way more analogous to the MRD we see in hematologic
malignancies, which of course are treated primarily with systemic therapies.
And because these cells are resistant to the prior line of therapy, this type
of MRD is relatively more challenging to treat.
The second type of MRD is MRD that occurs after
local therapy, and this is predominantly in patients with early-stage disease
who have a visible primary tumor, in this example here in the lung, but
also have micrometastatic deposits that are not recognized clinically.
Those patients undergo surgery and appear cancer-free, but still have the
micrometastatic disease, i.e., their minimal residual disease, that can then later
give rise to recurrence. The biological cause of this type of
MRD is the microscopic metastases, and this type of MRD
may be easier to treat because these cancer cells generally have not experienced
systemic therapy. So keep these two types of MRD in mind as we listen to
the upcoming speakers. Now, as a
Discovery Science Plenary, this session will span the spectrum from
basic biology through translation to the clinic.
And the first talk will be Dr. Hata focusing on evolution of drug
resistance in non-small cell lung cancer. The second talk by Dr.
Marine
focused on plasticity as a driver of MRD, particularly in melanomas.
The third talk will be by Dr. Landau and will be a bridging talk.
It will include some discussion of the biology of MRD, but
also begin to talk about how we detect MRD in patients with
early-stage
disease who have MRD. And then, to finish it off, Dr.
Ti will talk about advances in clinical trials and
recent clinical results and how we are using MRD in the clinic to personalize
treatment for patients.
And with that,
I will move on and introduce the
first speaker. Our first speaker is Dr. Aaron Hata.
He is an associate professor at Massachusetts General Hospital
and Harvard Medical School, and his talk is titled "From
Persistence to Relapse: Evolution of Drug Resistance in Lung Cancer."
Dr. Hata.
Good afternoon.
Here are my disclosures. Of note in this presentation, I will discuss
research performed as a sponsored research collaboration with Pfizer Oncology.
Over the past two decades, the treatment of advanced non-small
cell lung cancer has emerged as a success story of precision
oncology.
When a patient is diagnosed, we genotype their tumors to identify
oncogenic mutations in driver genes that dictate
which type of therapy the patient will receive.
These include mutations in receptor tyrosine kinases such as
EGFR, MET, and HER2, which lead to ligand-independent
constitutive activation;
gene fusions involving the kinase domains of receptor tyrosine
kinases such as ALK, ROS1, and RET, leading to expression, constitutive
dimerization, and activation; or mutations in downstream
signaling mediators such as RAS or RAF.
Currently, in the United States, there are over 25
FDA-approved targeted therapies targeting nine different
oncogenic drivers in lung cancer.
These therapies are quite effective, inducing deep and durable
regressions, leading to improved patient survival and quality of life.
However, these therapies are not curative, and complete
responses are rare. Inevitably, acquired drug resistance
develops, and leading to disease relapse at sites of residual disease.
I'd like to start today by telling you about a patient that we treated at our
cancer center about 10 years ago. This patient was diagnosed with EGFR
mutant lung cancer and was treated with the first-generation EGFR inhibitor,
erlotinib.When the patient progressed, we biopsied the
tumor and identified an EGFR T790M resistance mutation.
The patient then went on a clinical trial of an investigational third-generation
EGFR inhibitor that can overcome T790M.
We began to track the mutations in the blood, and as the patient responded, we
observed that the mutations became undetectable.
Unfortunately, this was short-lived, and the mutations returned along with a new
BRAF V600E mutation. This coincided with an
isolated progression in a liver lesion, which was biopsied, confirming the
BRAF mutation.
The patient then underwent cryoablation of that lesion,
after which point the BRAF mutation disappeared, but another EGFR resistance
mutation, C797S, emerged.
The patient came off the trial and was treated with subsequent lines of
chemotherapy, during which point some of the EGFR mutations went up in the blood
while others went down, highlighting different clonal responses to the
therapy.
Finally, the patient progressed again, and a biopsy revealed that the tumor had
transformed from non-small cell lung cancer to small cell lung cancer,
another known mechanism of resistance to EGFR TKIs.
This patient highlights the evolutionary nature of clinical acquired drug
resistance, which is continually shaped by the
shifting landscapes, the fitness landscapes that are created by the different
therapies that we treat our patients with.
My lab has become interested in understanding the mechanisms that
govern tumor evolution.
But to describe the way we think about tumor evolution, I need to go back to
this influential paper published in 2010 by Jeff Settleman and colleagues.
They showed that when cancer cell lines were treated with targeted therapies,
a small population of cancer cells could survive therapy.
They termed these cells drug-tolerant persisters, borrowing terminology
from bacterial persisters that had been described in the 1940s.
Bacterial persisters are subpopulations of bacteria that can survive an
environmental stress, such as an antibiotic, and then
repopulate when the antibiotic or the environmental stress is removed.
Importantly, bacterial persisters are distinct from resistant
bacteria in that they do not harbor fixed genetic resistance.
Similarly, drug-tolerant persisters do not harbor fixed
resistance but are characterized by epigenetic plasticity creating
drug tolerance that is reversible with withdrawal of the therapy.
Subsequently, in our work, we observed that EGFR mutant cell lines
consistently evolve T790M.
However, they did so with varying frequencies.
In some cases, resistance emerged very quickly after only a
few weeks, while in other cases, it took months or years.
We hypothesized that perhaps the late-evolving clones might
represent evolution of resistance from drug-tolerant persisters.
In subsequent work, we went on to demonstrate that yes, indeed, early
resistant clones
evolved from rare preexisting T790M clones that were present in the
population, whereas late resistance evolved from
persister cells that went on to de novo acquire resistance
mutations such as EGFR T790M or other mechanisms
of genomic resistance during the course of therapy.
These results demonstrated that at least in preclinical models,
clinical-acquired resistance could result from a multi-step evolutionary
process in which persister cells subsequently evolve genomic
mechanisms of resistance.
But what was challenging was to know whether or not this happened in the clinic,
owing to the limited nature of tumor sampling that we can achieve with
clinical tumor biopsies. However, given the stress
that these cells
undergo as they're in the persister state, we hypothesized that
perhaps there might be hallmarks or signatures of the stress that would be
reflected in the resistant tumors that might tell us which evolutionary
trajectory the tumor had evolved through.
To investigate this, we teamed up with Mike Lawrence at MGH to examine
the genomes of clones that had evolved resistance through the
persister trajectory and compared them to clones that have evolved from
preexisting T790M cells that effectively had never
been suppressed by drug.
We observed that cells evolving through the persister state
harbored a much higher tumor mutation burden, and specifically an increase
in APOBEC signature mutations.
APOBEC enzymes are a family of cytidine deaminases that catalyze the
deamination of cytosine to uracil in single-stranded DNA and
RNA.
APOBECs have come to be known as a major source of mutagenesis in
cancers, giving rise to C to T and C to G
mutations in TPC motifs comprising Sanger signatures
SBS2 and 13.
APOBEC mutational signatures are enriched in virally mediated
cancers such as HPV-associated head and neck cancer and cervical cancer,
but they also occur in non-virally mediated cancers such as subsets
of lung cancer and breast cancer.
We surveyed the 11 APOBEC family members in a
panel of EGFR and ALK lung cancer cell lines treated with targeted
therapies.
We observed heterogeneous expression levels of the different APOBECs, but
consistently, we saw that APOBEC3A was upregulated after
drug treatment and stayed elevated in persister cells.
To understand whether this led to increased mutagenesis in these cells, we
took advantage of the fact that APOBEC3A preferentially edits TPC
motifs within structurally conserved hairpin loops.
In particular,
an mRNA hotspot in the DDOSD transcript provides
a reliable way of assessing APOBEC editing in
the lab. We observed, consistent with the
increase in APOBEC3 expression, that RNA editing at this
DDOSC hotspot increased in EGFR and ALK mutant lung
cancer cell lines treated with targeted
therapy.We subsequently have
corroborated these findings by developing a live cell editing
reporter that can read out APOBEC editing in living intact
cells. In this reporter, we engineered APOBEC
substrate hairpin into a hiBIT sequence, which disrupts complementation
between hiBIT and largeBIT. Upon APOBEC3A editing,
the hiBIT is converted into a form that can complement
with largeBIT, generating a luminescent signal.
Using this reporter, we observed that drug-induced APOBEC
editing occurred within one to two days after treatment, and we were also
able to quantify APOBEC in living cells
representing different targeted therapy contexts and different APOBEC editing
levels.
So what are the consequences of APOBEC editing in persister cells?
Persister cells bear hallmarks of DNA damage, shown here by
increased gamma H2AX staining.
In addition, persister cells
exhibit increased double-strand DNA breaks, shown here by
comet assay.
When we knock down APOBEC3A in these cells, we can completely reverse the
increase in double-strand DNA breaks.
If we knock down APOBEC3B, we can also partially reverse this
phenotype.
To understand what the consequences of this induced genomic damage are
in the context of residual disease, we generated xenograft tumors from
knockdown cells or control cells, treated the mice to generate
residual disease, and then sequenced individual persister clones.
As expected, we noted increased APOBEC mutations and structural
variations in the control cells. However, in
APOBEC knockout cells, APOBEC mutations were
eliminated, as well as structural variations, demonstrating that therapy-induced
APOBEC mutagenesis can generate genomic instability in residual disease.
Finally, we examined whether or not APOBEC mutagenesis impacted the
evolution of drug resistance.
In control cells, we see cells initially respond and then
slowly become resistant as the persister clones grow out.
However, in APOBEC3A knockdown cells, this persister outgrowth
is largely abolished, suggesting that APOBEC3A-induced
mutagenesis is contributing to the evolution of drug resistance.
Finally, we examined whether patients that had progressed on targeted therapies
exhibit evidence of APOBEC mutations in their tumors.
In this cohort of patients, we observed increased APOBEC mutational
signatures in most treated resistant tumors.
And in most cases, these APOBEC mutations were not present before therapy.
I'd like to highlight one exemplary patient.
This was an ALK lung cancer patient that was treated with first, second, and
third-generation ALK inhibitors over the course of many years.
After progression on the first-generation inhibitor crizotinib, the patient was
observed to have an E1210K ALK resistance mutation.
When the patient was treated with brigatinib, they initially responded but then
experienced a series of isolated sites of disease progression which were
surgically resected.
In each of these, we observed the E1210K resistance mutation along
with another second ALK mutation in cis.
Finally, after progression on the third-generation inhibitor lorlatinib, we
observed the first two mutations with a third mutation.
In addition to these mutations, we observed an increased mutational burden in
each tumor during therapy, which was driven almost exclusively by an increase in
APOBEC mutagenesis.
We also noted that each individual resistance
mutation occurred in a characteristic APOBEC signature
motif in TPC motifs,
indicating that APOBEC was generating the resistance mutations that
caused tumor evolution in this patient.
These results nominate APOBEC3A as a driver of
persister evolution in lung cancers treated with targeted therapies and
also suggest that in some contexts, APOBEC3A may also generate the
resistance mutations that drive disease relapse.
Our work is supported by similar work by the Bivona and
Swanton groups that suggests that APOBEC3B can also have a role
in targeted therapy drug resistance.
And preceding our work, the idea of adaptive mutability was
proposed by the Bardelli group based on their discovery that in colorectal
cancers treated with EGFR and BRAF-directed therapies,
mismatch repair is downregulated and error polymerases are
upregulated, leading to increased DNA damage and mutability.
Collectively, these studies suggest that therapy-induced genomic
instability and increased mutagenesis may be a common
mechanism that shapes tumor evolution during therapy in multiple
different therapeutic contexts.
For the second half of the talk, I'd like to switch gears and talk about
unpublished work
ongoing in our lab looking at residual disease in ALK-positive lung
cancer. This project is led by an outstanding postdoc, Toshio
Fujino,
and started as a collaboration with Pfizer Oncology led by Darlin
Mannucci, a computational biologist.
Subsequently, this work has expanded and is now supported through a breakthrough
cancer project, namely the Power to Cure ALK-Positive Lung Cancer
Team Lab.
So ALK-positive lung cancer or patients with ALK-positive lung cancer have
experienced a rather dramatic improvement in
prognosis with the development of successive generations of
ALK-targeted therapies.
This is the progression-free survival data from the Phase III CROWN trial,
which tested the third-generation lorlatinib versus the
first-generation crizotinib in the first-line
setting.
And as you can appreciate, lorlatinib demonstrated impressive efficacy.
And at the last data cutoff with over six years of follow-up, the
median progression was not yet
achieved.Given this long duration of
response, lorlatinib resistance provides a biologically
compelling setting to study residual disease.
However, it also poses challenges in terms of sampling
tumors when deep responses are achieved by patients and the
sites of disease are quite small.
So to study residual disease in lorlatinib-treated ALK lung cancer,
we turn to PDX models.
Our cohort represented PDX models generated from
treatment-naive tumors, which model first-line lorlatinib use,
as well as models generated from patients who had experienced acquired
resistance to early-generation ALK inhibitors with on-target
resistance and remain sensitive to lorlatinib.
These models can model residual disease in the second-line
lorlatinib setting.
We treated PDX tumor-bearing mice and sampled tumors before
treatment at the point of maximal response in residual disease,
and for those models that became resistant at the time of disease relapse.
As you can see, these models recapitulate a range of disease
responses, some with rather shallow disease responses, others with
deep regressions, and the duration to response and time to
resistance was variable,
representing heterogeneity that we see in our patients.
Here is an example of a residual tumor in which small
persister clusters are maintained within an expanded
stromal compartment.
To characterize persister evolution in this context, we performed single-cell
sequencing on residual tumors in the first-line
lorlatinib-resistant context.
After data integration, we performed pseudo-time analysis and mapped the
pseudo-time clusters on treatment time points to generate a
putative resistance trajectory spanning from
pre-treatment tumors through residual disease and to
relapse.
Of note, we identified two clusters shown here as cluster five and
cluster seven, which represented transitional clusters that
bridged the transition from untreated tumors to
residual disease.
First, we looked at markers of lung lineage states.
This enabled us to map putative lineage trajectories on top
of our pseudo-time trajectory, highlighting a high degree of
lineage plasticity over this treatment context, starting with
AT2-like cells that subsequently evolve into multiple
lineage states.
In addition, we identified intermediate states including cluster
one, which expressed SLC4A11, which is a
recently described marker of a high plasticity cell state in
cancer,
as well as bridging clusters such as cluster seven,
which exhibited a high expression of keratin 17 and other basal
cell-like markers such as keratin five and TP63.
We also observed lineage-specific upregulation
of markers such as ERBB2, which have been described to
drive adaptive resistance in ALK-positive
preclinical models of drug resistance.
Given the location of cluster seven on the lineage
trajectory, we focused on it. We also noticed that this cluster
expressed high levels of CD44, a cancer stem cell
marker supporting the
potential lineage plasticity of this cluster.
Additionally, we observed expression of integrins as well as
genes associated with extracellular matrix.
Particularly, we observed expression of components of
laminin 322, which is the main extracellular matrix
protein that interacts with integrin alpha 6 beta 4,
as well as multiple components of the basement membrane component
collagen IV.
These results suggested that cluster seven might resemble cells that are
interacting with the tumor microenvironment.
In multiple recent studies, keratin 17-positive aberrant
basal cells have been identified in non-cancer
lung disease states such as idiopathic pulmonary fibrosis, where
they orchestrate a pathological lung epithelial repair
response.
In addition, aberrant basaloid cells and related
damage-associated transitional progenitors have
been identified in other inflammatory lung diseases such as severe
COVID infection.
These cells represent dysfunctional injury repair.
So in the setting of normal lung injury, the repair process
involves transdifferentiation from AT2 cells to AT1
cells. However, in pathological states,
this repair process becomes dysfunctional with the
generation of intermediate injury states such as alveolar
damage intermediates or damage-associated
transitional progenitor cells.
Interactions between macrophages in the microenvironment and
fibroblasts and these damaged epithelial cells can generate a
positive feed-forward cycle mediated by
TGF-beta, TNF alpha, and the deposition of extracellular matrix
proteins that enforces a keratin 17 positive aberrant
basaloid state, which promotes further inflammation and
fibrosis.
We wondered whether the keratin 17 positive cells that we observed in residual
tumors might similarly be interacting with the tumor microenvironment.
Indeed, pathological analysis of residual tumors indicated that these
cells lined the tumor stroma boundary, suggesting that they're promoted
by interactions with the microenvironment.
So we hypothesized that during lorlatinib treatment, persister
evolution might promote the keratin 17 positive state by
interactions between CAFs and other components of the
microenvironment.To study this, we generated
ex vivo co-culture models generated from patient-derived tumor cells and
patient-derived cancer-associated fibroblast cells from ALK lung cancer
patients. By culturing these cells in 3D, the organoid
models are able to recapitulate the tumor stroma boundaries.
And we observe that even in the absence of treatment, tumor cells that lined
the interface with fibroblasts upregulated expression of
keratin 17.
Next, to study the transition into the keratin 17 positive state,
we generated reporter cell lines in which the induction of
keratin 17 leads to expression of GFP, allowing us to
visualize the cell state transition.
When cultured by themselves, tumor cells rarely expressed keratin 17 or
the GFP reporter. However, when cultured with fibroblasts,
we observed that tumor cells in close approximation with a fibroblast
upregulated keratin 17.
Furthermore, when we treated these co-cultures with lorlatinib,
we were able to induce further differentiation into the
keratin 17 positive cell state.
Next, we examined different components of the tumor microenvironment,
including laminin 322, implicated in our single-cell sequencing,
as well as markers such as TNF alpha and TGF beta, which
are expressed by our fibroblasts and have been shown to induce a keratin 17
positive state in lung injury contexts.
By themselves, these microenvironment components induce
variable levels of keratin 17
positivity, but when combined with lorlatinib, this was
enhanced.
When we compare the induction of keratin 17 positive cells
across these
conditions, we can define a continuum of
inducing efficiency
suggesting that different components of the microenvironment might collaborate
together to promote the generation of keratin 17
positive tumor cells.
To confirm that our GFP reporter was faithfully recapitulating the
keratin 17 positive cell state that we observed in residual tumors,
we sorted GFP-high and GFP-low
cells
from these different states, and we examined expression of keratin
17 as well as other basaloid markers such as keratin
five and keratin 14, which we confirmed were also expressed
in the GFP-high cells.
Finally, we asked whether or not the keratin 17 basaloid state might
have a role in drug resistance.
When we treated cancer cells with lorlatinib in the presence of
the microenvironment components, we observed decreased drug
sensitivity and increased persistence, suggesting that the keratin
17 state may reflect an increased drug-tolerant
population.
Taken together, these results suggest that tumor
persister evolution in ALK-positive lung cancer residual disease
may reflect the dysfunctional epithelial regeneration
states seen in non-cancer lung injury contexts,
whereby cues from the microenvironment may enhance
formation of a keratin 17 basal-like
state with decreased drug sensitivity and increased lineage
plasticity.
We speculate that these cells may further evolve resistant states that
recapitulate additional lung lineage trajectories.
Our work
supports the notion that
lineage plasticity inherent in epithelial regeneration
may promote residual disease.
In a landmark study from 2020 from the Bivona group,
they profiled residual tumors in lung cancer patients treated
with targeted therapies.
They
observed a signature of alveolar injury and repair in persisting
cancer cells in this state.
In earlier this year, work from the Tamela group using mouse models
of KRAS mutant lung cancer identified a high plasticity cell
state that promoted tumor evolution and therapy
resistance. Interestingly, they noted that the
high plasticity cell state resembled some of the
epithelial damage intermediates seen in non-cancer lung injury
states.
They also showed that non-cancer injury states could
regenerate high plasticity cells.
Collectively, these data support the
paradigm in which lineage plasticity, which is
governed by the normal lung differentiation axis
and is reflected in the dysfunctional cell states
in
diseases such as idiopathic pulmonary fibrosis that are driven
by lung injury,
may also promote but also constrain persister
evolution in targeted therapy persistent disease, being
influenced by cell intrinsic properties as well as
microenvironmental cues.
So to conclude,
today I hope I've showed you that therapy-persistent cancer cells in residual
disease can acquire drug-resistant mechanisms through multi-step evolution.
Therapy-induced adaptive mutagenesis can accelerate evolution
of persister cells and drive disease relapse.
And lineage-constrained lung epithelial injury states may provide a useful
paradigm for understanding and targeting the early stages of
therapy-persistent residual disease.
With that, I'd like to conclude by acknowledging the large team of people that
contributed to this work, some of whom I mentioned along the way.
And I'd like to also acknowledge our funders, without whom this work would not be
possible.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Hata.
Our next speaker is Dr. Chris Marine.
He is a professor at the VBI at the
University of Leuven in Belgium.
His talk is titled, "Therapeutic Strategies to Address Cancer Cell
Heterogeneity and Plasticity."
Cancer cell plasticity.
So cancer cell plasticity has emerged recently,
as you have heard,
as a key driver of therapy resistance.
And this is satisfying for us because our lab has been promoting this idea for the
last 10 years or so.
But today, I'll
flip the script a bit and
I will show you that cancer plasticity can actually be leveraged
to our advantage in order to mitigate therapy
resistance.
In fact,
the idea is that,
I will try to discuss this today, that plasticity might actually
be a solution rather than a problem that we have to cope with.
So my lab focus and work on melanoma,
and like many other cancer types,
targeted therapy has become one standard of care treatment.
In this context, BRAF mutant patient melanoma are
exposed to a combination of BRAF and MEK inhibitors.
This treatment
leads to very dramatic antitumor responses in patients, but as you all
know resistance always develop.
And this is obviously because this treatment does not kill all tumor cells.
And one of the interesting question is
why is that?
And so obviously, not all tumor cells are created equals.
While some cells may be eliminated by the treatment, others may undergo cell
cycle arrest or even worse, continue cycling in response to the
treatment.
And in fact, in the context of melanoma, this is unfortunately very common.
Melanoma, as you may recall, is the tumor type with the highest mutation
burden. So it actually is very common to detect
before therapy is
applied,
numbers of cells that have already acquired genetic alterations
that confer resistance to the treatment.
Such as, for example, a mutation in the MEK1 gene or NRAS gene.
And so when these tumors are exposed to the treatment, resistance
rapidly emerge due to the selection of this preexisting
subclone.
So there is basically a clear genetic evidence in the context of melanoma
of tumor evolution, and this occurs in about 50% of the cases.
Now, besides genetic alterations, plasticity
can be obviously a potential source of phenotypic diversity.
But does it play an important role in melanoma, given that melanoma is the tumor
type with the highest mutation burden?
So to address these questions, we leveraged single-cell RNA sequencing, collected
numbers of clinical samples, as well as lesions from different mouse models,
and realized that indeed, melanoma cells are not all created equal.
They exist in a lineage-specific continuum of cell
states.
Some cells, for example, turn on a melanocytic
program or MEL program which is characterized by high expression
of pigment-producing genes, such as those found in
normal melanocytes,
while other cells shift along a dedifferentiation trajectory and
turn on a transitory or fetal embryonic neural
crest-like or even mesenchymal-like state.
When cells turn on the mesenchymal-like phenotype, these cells lose almost
completely their melanocytic identity, and we therefore refer to
this as dedifferentiation.
The key observation is that this transcriptomic heterogeneity is
not driven by the genetic makeup of the cells.
For example, here we leveraged sequencing-based spatial
transcriptomics to demonstrate that most
metastatic melanoma lesions we looked at are
genetically monoclonal, yet they exhibit
transcriptomic heterogeneity.
So these experiments, among others, led us to conclude that cell
plasticity does contribute to phenotypic diversity, even in the context
of melanoma.
But does it contribute to therapy resistance, and in particular, to the
drug tolerance?
And to address this question, we generated PDX models from patients that
responded well to the treatment.
Treatment of these mice mirror what we see in
patients, so meaning that tumors regress in these mice and eventually all
recur on treatment.
So to disentangle the
contribution of the genetic versus non-genetic mechanism of tumor
evolution
in these models, we
collected cells at different time point and apply GNT-seq,
allowing us to sequence the genome and transcriptome of the same cells.
What we've learned looking at the genome is that we didn't find any evidence of
subclonal genetic evolution or selection at minimal residual
disease. And when we look at the transcriptome, we
notice that the dedifferentiated neural crest-like or the mesenchymal cells were
the
cells that were accumulated the most at MRD on treatment.
And importantly, accumulation of these dedifferentiated cells was a consequence of
two things. One, a passive selection of a
rare preexisting subpopulation, but also in some
case, due to adaptive reprogramming and
induction of this program due to the therapy
itselfIndicating that even in the context of melanoma,
plasticity does contribute to the drug tolerance.
So based on this data, we then design strategies that prevent
emergence of these de-differentiated cells or that target these cells
at MRD. For example, we use
inhibitors of specific transcription factors or epigenetic modifiers,
or to target
the vulnerabilities of these persistent cells at MRD, we use, for example,
focal adhesion kinase inhibitors or inhibitors of de novo lipid synthesis.
Now, although all of these strategies delay time to progression
significantly in PDX models, none of those strategies,
even when combined, were actually curative.
And the reason for this is that we realized that minimal residual disease in the
context of melanoma is more complex than we initially thought.
De-differentiation is only part of
the story.
In fact, we identify at least four different drug
persistent cell phenotypes that could eventually
co-emerge in one single MRD.
For example, here on the left, we have a PDX-derived MRD that
shows three different persistent phenotypes that occupy a
geographically distinct region in this lesion.
On the right, you have numbers of
MRDs from clinical samples, and what you can see is that each MRD in
melanoma is a complex ecosystem with very distinct cellular
makeup.
So our work uncover extreme genotypic heterogeneity and
phenotypic diversity in melanoma.
And not only we find that the cellular makeup of MRD is complex,
heterogeneous, and patient-specific,
we also find evidence that distinct genetic and non-genetic evolutionary
mechanisms can be at play in different lesions from the same patient or
worst, in a single individual
lesion.
So this data highlighted the challenges of personalized treatment in the
context of melanoma. In fact,
it's almost as if we need to develop
lesion-specific therapy as opposed to personalized therapy.
And so all this to say that what we think is that personalized
therapy in melanoma should still be a long-term goal.
The clinical implementation will be extremely challenging and therefore,
not necessarily for tomorrow, unfortunately.
So we reason that
one way to approach this problem would be to move beyond personalized therapy.
What if we could develop therapeutic
regimens that are effective irrespective of the genetic background, the cellular
makeup of the cells, and that can contend with cancer cell plasticity?
This would obviously be fantastic, but is that
realistic?
Adrian De Blonder, a post-doc in the lab,
decided to tackle this rather provocative
approach question.
And the first thing he did is to try to develop a new framework
in which cancer cell plasticity and heterogeneity are no longer
defined by complex multi-omics signatures.
So
basically, he was inspired by the definition of phenotype,
which was first coined as the observable traits or appearance of an
organism,
and decided to look more carefully at our melanoma cells.
And indeed, looking at melanoma cells under the microscope, we realized that
cells that exhibit very distinct transcriptomic signatures look
quite distinct morphologically.
So we then teamed up with a company called DeepCell that developed a
high-resolution live-cell imaging and deep learning platform
that allows to classify cells according to morphometrics measurements.
And we profiled more than 20 different
melanoma cell lines spanning a wide range of genetic as
well as transcriptomic profiles.
And remarkably, we realized that
melanoma cells that exhibit common transcriptomic features
occupy discrete UMAP areas in these
UMAP plots,
indicating that morphometrics could be used as a way to
decode melanoma cell state diversity.
Adrian then
did a numbers of trial and errors and developed a very simple FACS method that we
call Origami, that measure only two different parameters, the
cell surface area and the volume.
To measure the cell surface area, Adrian used membrane, which is a
dye that stains lipid to the cell surface, and as a proxy for cell
volume, Adrian used forward scatter width.
And with this very simple, scalable, and cost-efficient method, we now can
capture the entire diversity of melanoma cell state.
Here, for example, I've shown a dozen of melanoma cell lines that are
representative of the four transcriptomic states, and you can see they are well
separated onto this UMAP plot, onto this
two-dimensional space.
What's interesting about this approach is that you can basically define cell
state in the absence of any omic measurements.
Here we propose to define on this
cell geometric framework to define cell state at the position or the
coordinate of a cell into this SV space.
We adapted this method, Origami, to able to monitor
intratumor heterogeneity in clinical samples.
We needed to add lineage depletion steps.
So we basically depleted now all the
immune cells as well as the fibroblast before proceeding to the SV
measurement. The whole procedure take only 20 minutes, and as you can
see, the SV readout is a very good proxy or basically a very good
predictor of the tumor cell composition of these biopsies
as defined by single-cell RNA sequencing on the same clinical
sample.So the point I'd like to make is
that there is great value at developing more and more sophisticated
approaches to gain new biological insights.
But impact can also be achieved by creating very simple and cheap alternatives,
such as origami, which can be implemented
very quickly into clinical routine.
Now,
this method can also be used to study adaptation to treatment.
And for example, here, in response to the standard of care treatment, so BRAF/MEK
inhibitors, you can see that cells can adapt, and
the surviving cells can change their morphology in different ways.
And this is very similar to what I told you earlier, meaning that in response
to the particular treatment, melanoma cells can turn on
different persistent phenotypes.
Now,
measuring cancer cell plasticity has always been rather challenging,
and it was a bit unclear how to do that.
So what we're proposing is that this cell geometry framework could be a simple
way to monitor cancer cell plasticity.
Indeed, the ability of cells to travel within this two-dimensional space
is a good proxy or good readout of cancer cell plasticity.
So now that we can use this very simple method to monitor and to quantify
cell plasticity, the next question is, can we actually control
plasticity?
This, of course, therapeutically, it would be far more interesting.
So instead of using drugs such as the standard of care treatment, the BRAF/MEK
inhibitors, that promotes divergent
persistent trajectories, we thought that
identifying drugs or combination of drugs that promote a
uniform and predictable trajectory would be quite
exciting and would, of course, dramatically help the
development of
rational combination strategies.
So we searched for a number of combinations that would
promote uniform adaptation strategy, and what we found
is this TP, this combination,
trametinib, palbociclib, so a MEK inhibitor and
CDK4/CDK6 inhibitor, promote indeed this
uniform type of adaptive mechanism.
Here you can see cells from 20 different cell
lines, spanning again a wide range of genotypes and phenotypes adapting
to the trametinib/palbociclib combination.
You see that the cells move along this mel to mes
trajectory and tend to increase the cell volume.
So we were quite excited and surprised by the fact
that this combination is able to induce a uniform
adaptive response irrespective of the genotype and the phenotype of the cells.
And again, we were quite excited about this because therapeutically, this could be
exploited.
So we searched a number of ways through which we could target these cells
that increase the cell volume, so the persistent cells with the high volume,
and realized using transcriptomic methods that these cells exhibit
features of
autophagy and
increase lysosome biogenesis,
which was confirmed using a number of techniques such as FACS
analysis here shown on the right for two different cell lines exposed
to the TP combination. You see an increase in cell
volume and a concomitant increase in
lysosomal content.
This was exciting to us because the work of Rafael Rodriguez, a
colleague from Curie Institute in Paris, has developed
a number of agents that promote the sequestration of iron in
lysosomes
as a means to promote or to increase the sensitivity to
ferroptosis.
So we reasoned that these high
volume persistent cells of melanoma that have a high lysosomal content
might be extremely sensitive to these agents. And it was indeed the case.
You can see here, for example, in response to nilotinib, these cells undergo
cell death. And consistent with the work of Rafael
Rodriguez, this
phenotype can be rescued by using ferroptosis inhibitors.
So we conclude that this adaptation to this TP
combination increases a liability that can be
targeted using lysosome-targeting agents.
We further validate that in a number of melanoma cell lines, including
dedifferentiated cell lines. So we expose them to TP and
TPN, so TP plus nilotinib, and as you can see, nilotinib
sensitizes these dedifferentiated cells to the combination
TP.
We also explore the therapeutic potential of nilotinib in vivo in
various preclinical models, here in the PDX model,
NRAS-derived. And as you can see, in response to TP, there is emergence
of these persistent cells with high volume,
so much so that we can even visualize this with a simple H&E staining.
Importantly, nilotinib indeed increase
overall survival
in this mouse compared to TP.
Unfortunately, this combination was not
curative at this stage. And so we then looked at these
lesions that were under TPN and realized that
nilotinib indeed is very effective at killing these high volume persistent
cells, but there remain a number of cells that have a high
surface and low volume.
So we had to develop strategies to target these remaining
high
surface persistent cells and decided to perform a cell
phenotyping drug screens, again using origami as a tool.
We look for drugs that decrease the cell surface, thinking that these
drugs would sensitize to
TPWe
screened the numbers of libraries.
I will show you here a pilot study where we
identified three different drugs, here highlighted in red, all targeting the
ER Golgi apparatus, and importantly,
all decreasing the cell surface area,
again, in a genotype and phenotype-independent manner.
So you can see here, again, these 20 different cell lines spanning a
wide range of genotype and phenotype in response to one of these
drugs, which is brefeldin A.
Satisfyingly,
these drugs, while decreasing the cell surface,
sensitize these high surface cells to
TP. You can see here again, this mesenchymal or
this
melanoma, they differentiate these cells under TP or TP plus
brefeldin A. You can see that there is a dramatic sensitization in vitro.
Then, of course, we tested the quadruple combination.
So we tested
whether or not targeting both the high volume and high
surface persist cells could indeed wipe out
completely the melanoma cells that we have in the lab.
And you can see here that indeed, most melanoma cell lines under this
quadruple combination
suffer drastically
in vitro. In vivo, this quadruple
combination, TPNB, was also very efficient.
Just focus on the Kaplan-Meier curve here on the bottom, you see
that this TPNB combination delayed time to progression
for more than one year and was even curative in some cases, which is something we
had never seen before. This also told us that this
combination is well-tolerated in mice up to one
year.
All this was very exciting to us, as it showed that this
combination
was very efficient
and could be effective irrespective of the genotype and
the phenotype of the cells.
Now, the excitement does not stop here.
Indeed,
as you may know,
in addition to being not curative, the current standard of
care treatment
has additional problems, one of which is that patients that progress on
targeted therapy in melanoma often end up non-responding to
another major standard of care, which is immune checkpoint blockade, ICB.
And so, in fact, as a consequence of that, targeted therapy
in melanoma is no longer considered as first-line treatment.
So we were very pleased to see that a combination, TPNB, actually
triggered response to ECV, even in tumors that acquire resistance to targeted
therapy. For these experiments, we used a model that was developed in Anna
Oberhofer's group in IMP in Vienna.
These mice are extremely refractory to both targeted therapy and
immunotherapy.
Here to
test different drug combinations, we used a medical
device developed by Oliver Jonas and his colleague that allow
intratumor delivery of multiple drugs, up to 20 different
drugs, and microdosing directly into tumor.
So it's a very
exciting way to perform pharmacologic
perturbation
in vivo in tumors in a specially controlled manner.
So here in these mice, we treated them with TP and anti-PD-1 systemically, and you
can see that didn't lead to any anti-tumor effects, but the
delivery of nilotinib and brefeldin A drastically induced
an immune response,
and eventually led to a complete loss of cellularity
close to the drug diffusion area. Again, confirming
the high potency of this combination, even in this particular
highly refractory tumor model.
This combination also sensitized another immune checkpoint
blockade-resistant model,
one model that we
presented last year, which harbored this immune-excluded phenotype.
Again, this combination drastically sensitized to immune checkpoint blockade,
promoted immune cell infiltration, and T cell activation.
So one of the questions
is why is this combination so active at promoting
an anti-tumor immune response and exacerbate response to
anti-PD-1?
And that's not something that we had planned initially, but we realized that this
combination actually activates all the hallmarks of immunogenic cell death.
It activates stress response pathways.
It promotes
the release of DAMPs, so damage-associated
molecular patterns such as HMGB1, for example, as shown on the
right. It increases expression and presentation of
antigen,
such as melanocytic antigens.
So let me leave you with
a couple of take-home messages. So the first one is that our work has
uncovered the idea that
personalized treatment and MRD-based therapy in melanoma is
going to be very challenging. There are many routes towards resistance.
There's obviously the classical genetic routes, but importantly,
we will show that even in melanoma, plasticity plays an important role in
driving resistance to therapy.
In order to study plasticity and eventually
to control it, we develop a physics-based framework that allow us to
now monitor cell state, monitor plasticity,
and drug-tolerant persist cell biology from a different angle,
from the lens of cell morphology. This has several
advantages. There's no need to perform complex
multi-omics type of staining.
This is cheap, simple,
and importantly, it's broadly applicable.
See, for example, here, where we can physically
separate
well-known
phenotypic
subgroups of breast cancer cell line, for example, and this works well for other
tumor types as well.But
importantly, and the key message of this talk is that
we have developed a
therapeutic strategy. It's a conceptual therapeutic strategy that harness
cancer cell plasticity. And the idea is that we are
using plasticity, steering the entire tumor population into
one uniform and predictable trajectory.
A model or a therapeutic strategy
that referred to as the field-oriented therapeutic strategy, or less elegantly,
the steel and wipe out approach.
The idea is that we want the
decrease in heterogeneity on one hand, and then we create
vulnerability on the other.
We have provided proof of concept evidence that this therapeutic
strategy is actually effective in vivo.
And one of the reason why the therapeutic strategy is so effective in vivo is
that not only it kill tumor cells, but it also promote a
bystander killing due to activation of immunogenic cell death.
So where do we go from there?
The first obvious
approach is to
convert this experimental combination into a clinically compatible
combination. We need to replace some of the experimental
drugs, such as brefeldin A, by FDA-approved drugs.
We have already performed an FDA-approved drug screens and identify
candidates that we are now further exploring.
But importantly, and the most exciting next step would be how do we bring
these combinations to
patients? Indeed, there is no clear regulatory path to test multiple drug
combination in patients. So there is an acute need to develop
strategies that allow us to accelerate this process.
And one of the approach we are very excited about is the use of
intra tumor microdosing or the use of
devices that allow to deliver
intratumorally different drugs
such as the device developed by Presage, a company with whom we have
initiated collaborations at Leuven.
In fact, we initiated the first clinical trial of this kind in
Europe, in which patients with metastatic melanoma
received their first-line standard of care treatment,
in which we inject seven different drugs intratumorally using the
Presage device.
And we looked at the response and whether or not some of these drugs sensitize
these tumors to standard of care treatment using a
spatial multi-omics approach.
The first data are coming in, and we are very excited about that because we are now
in a position to be able to test
the most promising combination of drugs that we find from
our preclinical models directly in tumors from patients,
and thereby accelerate drastically the clinical
implementation.
And with that, I'll stop here. I thank the collaborators,
the funders, and obviously my lab, and in particular Adrian, for his vision
and for being so dedicated to the project I showed you today, which is
unpublished
story. And I thank you for your attention.
Thank you, Dr. Marine.
Our third speaker in this session will be Dr. Dan Landau.
He's a professor at Weill Cornell Medicine and the New York
Genome Center. His talk is titled "The Hidden Lives of Cancer Cells:
Somatic Evolution, Cellular Plasticity, and the Detection of Residual
Disease."
Here are my disclosures.
So the focus of this session is residual disease as a central challenge in
oncology. We have powerful treatment that can eliminate most
cancer cells, and yet some of them are different in some
way, and they
remain behind. And those cells are the ones that return in the form of lethal
metastatic disease. Today, I'd like to tell you about work that
relates to two aspects of this work or this problem.
The first is how do we retrace the evolutionary history of the disease, and the
second is how do we use the genome as a sensor to read out residual
disease and predict future outcome.
So we understand that cancers are heterogeneous, cancer cells are
heterogeneous, and that underlies their ability to resist therapy.
However, we typically study this heterogeneity using
different powerful lenses that are rarely actually integrated.
And one of the missions of our lab, as part of a larger field effort,
is to generate novel single-cell multi-omics technologies
that can bring those different perspectives together at the
level of the single cell, because the single cell constitute the atomic
evolutionary
unit. So what we try to do is profile or
capture multiple modalities at the level of the single cell.
So not RNA or DNA, but both and so forth.
But what we're missing in this framework is the component of time, right?
All the information we have is at a single snapshot when the
sample is collected. What happens over the course of evolution
in these individuals?Now, evolutionary biology gives
us a temporal microscope, if you like, to trace back
the history of cancer.
And it allows us to go back and understand when did clonal rise, how
fast are they growing? But today, I'd also like to argue that it can tell us
something about the phenotypic evolution.
And to explain what I mean,
consider cell states like we heard today from the previous speakers, but
also epithelial-mesenchymal transitions or cancer stemness,
and the fundamental question of whether those cell states are actually heritable.
Can they be propagated across cell division from parent to progeny?
And this phylogenetic tree can help answer that question.
So if we can generate a high-resolution phylogenetic tree directly from a
patient sample, and can annotate the terminal nodes or the leaves of the
tree with this phenotypic cell state, we can distinguish
between scenarios like this tree on the left-hand side, where
you can see that it's very structural.
That's how a heritable tree looks like versus this, where
the phenotype is distributed much more randomly.
Josh Schiffman in the lab developed a quantitative
framework, a phylodynamic framework that allows us to measure this.
So we use Moran's I, a metric of phylogenetic
autocorrelation. What it basically asks is, if I have two cells that are
found together on the tree, closely on the tree, and I'm looking at a particular
phenotype, will that phenotype match up?
And the idea is that if it's heritable, neighboring cells on the tree
should share this phenotype. But it also offer a
potential novel and quantitative measurable definition of cancer cell
plasticity. It's one minus heritability. It's the complement of heritability.
If a cell has to have the same phenotype as its parent, then there's no
freedom of will. There's no plasticity.
If a cell can toggle between those cell state, then there's high degree of
plasticity.
So how do we generate those high-resolution phylogenetic tree directly from patient
samples? In model organism, we have all these advanced tools,
CRISPR screening tools to generate high-resolution trees.
But in patients, we have to rely on retrospective
lineage reconstruction. We have to use native marks.
And Fede Gaite, who's now faculty at Princess Margaret, Renaud Chanier, who's at
MSK,
a few years back, noticed that when we collect single-cell methylomes,
we are able to capture what we call epimutations, stochastic
changes to DNA methylation that are just happening as errors when
the cell
genome is copied and are yet heritable and can be
used to reconstruct phylogenies.
So with this approach, together with Marjo Suva, we
profiled glioblastoma cells. And I'm showing here one example where we can use
the methylation data to reconstruct the phylogenetic tree
directly from a primary patient sample. This is a single time point sample.
And because we work with the single-cell multi-omics, we also have RNA from the
same cell, and we can annotate the different cell state that Marjo and
colleagues have described are so important to biology of disease.
Stem-like cell state, astrocytic, mesenchymal, and so forth.
And we show that they are actually heritable, meaning that they are propagated
from parent to progeny across cell division.
Now we can take this a step further, and instead of looking at what we call
phylogenetic autocorrelation, whether that phenotype is found on neighboring
cells of the tree, we can look at the relationship between two cell states.
Would those two cell state actually be neighboring on the tree as well,
suggesting that they have high degree of transition?
And when we do this analysis, we can, from a single time point sample,
estimate what are the transition probability between cell states.
And here we see that to move from a stem-like cell state into mesenchymal,
there is a necessary intermediary, which is the astrocytic cell state.
Further, we can interrogate differentiation
hierarchy. For example, we find that in IDH-mutant
gliomas, the differentiation hierarchy is largely preserved as
unidirectional, moving from stem to mature.
But in IDH wild-type glioblastoma, the differentiation hierarchy is
corrupted. It's bidirectional. There's also dedifferentiation.
Some of the stem cells that we're seeing are originating from mature cell that are
dedifferentiating. And that's important because there's a paradigm in glioma that
argues that we should target those stem cells.
But if mature cells can replenish the rank, that of course changes
how we should consider this.
Now, recently, work by Jyoti Nangalia and Peter Campbell at the Sanger and
others have
shown that in blood, we can collect hematopoietic stem cells,
grow them ex vivo in culture, and then submit them to whole genome sequencing,
and then use all the mutations that are found in the genome to reconstruct
the phylogenetic tree. And notably, this is a phylogenetic tree that can look
further into the past, all the way to the moment of conception.
And in this fascinating example, they showed that a tumor that was a
blood cancer, that was diagnosed at adulthood, actually originated from
a mutation that likely occurred in utero.
This is super exciting, but there are limitations.
You have to have live cells. They have to be culturable ex vivo,
and you're limited in probing the phenotype because, by
virtue of culturing them
in vitro, you are obviously disrupting the phenotype.
Single-cell whole-genome amplification could be an alternative route, but
up until very recently, the quality of the data was just not sufficient
to generate these phylogenies, and that has been recently
solved through a protocol that was developed by Chakra
Wad called primary template amplification that is really a massive step
forward in the quality of whole genome.
However, there are issues with scalability.
The cost, the labor, the time that's associated with producing this data
means that most of the published datasets that are out there involve only
dozens of cells.Just to give you one flavor, to generate
1,000 single-cell whole genomes, we need
35,000 pipette tips. And there's a team in the lab that came up with a
way to address all of the different cost and labor and time component, such that
we can really turn it into something that's more scalable.
We call this smart PTA.
Using this approach, we generated 3,500
matched whole genome and transcriptome from phenotypically normal
esophagus. This is the tissue that was shown by the Sanger colleague to
be completely replaced, carpeted with clones as we age,
clones bearing mutations in driver genes such as Notch1 and TP53.
And with this data, we can then retrace the evolution of those
cells. So we have cells that we collect from a 75-year-old, and
then we can trace their evolution all the way to the moment of conception.
And we can understand how different clones arose, when they
arose, and also what are the pattern of growth and can show you an example from
a clone here that grew stably over time versus another
clone where you see that there is an inflection point matching with a
massive increase in proliferation rate, which coincides with the
acquisition of a driver mutation.
In another example, we can look at TP53 mutated clones, and we find that
in phenotypically normal tissue, there's nothing wrong with this tissue under the
microscope, we find TP53 clones. And not only that, some of them have
complete biallelic inactivation.
And yet, based on the phylogenetic reconstruction, we know that they are
in the tissue for 10, 15 years,
and that really challenges us to think again about what is that
elusive cancer Rubicon that separates the non-transformed
from a transformed cell.
Back to the glioma example, again, in collaboration with Mario Suva's lab,
we collected 2,500 single cell with whole genome and
transcriptome.
And here you can see that we can reconstruct the phylogeny of those cells
from the moment of origination and again, ask the
fundamental question of are those cell states heritable?
Now we have a positive control that's a genetic lesion, obviously
highly heritable. We have a negative control sequencing depth that's just
a technical feature. And all of those
features in between are those cell states, stem-like cell state, mesenchymal,
that again are showing a marker of heritability.
As I mentioned, we can also estimate transition probability and again validate
between stem and mesenchymal. We have to go through an astrocytic cell state.
And again, this is from a single time point primary patient
sample. But when we look at different tumor regions, we see
differences. In peritumoral areas, we see a push towards dedifferentiation,
towards more stem-like cell state that's consistent with those cells
enabling the
invasion of glioma into normal brain parenchyma.
In necrotic core, we see a push towards more mature cell state, likely
reflecting the intense infiltration by tumor microenvironment and myeloid
cells.
Because we have single-cell whole genomes, we can also study a feature
of glioma, a very interesting feature of glioma, extra chromosomal
DNA, and we can solve the breakpoints of the amplicon and the copy
number at the single-cell level and identify the remarkable
ability of those
extra chromosomal fragments to evolve.
Within just a few hundred samples, we discovered more than 12 different
version of EGFR extra chromosomal DNA, ecDNA,
that all started from the same amplicon and then are continuously
sculpted and remodeled as the tumor evolved.
There's another feature that's, I think,
surprising and fascinating, and I'm just simplifying here.
There are two versions of this ecDNA.
There's a six mega base version and then a derivative of that of a one mega
base version. And you can see that although they segregate by the different
clades, there are also instances where even neighboring
cells in a phylogeny have different versions of this ecDNA.
Sometimes both are found within the same cell, again, testifying to
how the inheritance is unexpected and does not
follow a Mendelian pattern.
And lastly, we can also ask questions about migration.
How do cells move from one place to the other?
And in fact, these frameworks draw on frameworks that use
phylogenetics, for example, to estimate patterns of migrations in early human
history. We can identify which areas of the
tree show higher degrees of mixing that likely move
around and then correlate it with the phenotype when we observe that the
phenotype seem to converge towards a stem-like cell state, again,
testifying to the ability of those cells to infiltrate the normal parenchyma
as well as an invasion signature.
So just to summarize this first part, I'm excited about this
new way of studying this problem, this
high-resolution phylogenetic tree that in addition has the ability to
annotate the terminal nodes or the leaves with phenotypes.
This allows us to ask really fundamental question about heritability,
plasticity, as well as measure cell state transition
in humans, in a primary patient sample.
And we hope to build new technologies that could scale this up to hundreds of
thousands of cells and millions of cells.
But there is another factor that I think is interesting to point out.
When we think about inheritance, we think about memory.
It's a common experience in oncology that each
cycle of therapy results in shorter and shorter remissions.
Something is being remembered and propagated across cell
division to new generations of cancer cells.
And we can ask the question with these trees, what is the mode of
propagation? How is the information inherited?
How is it passed along? Is it through genetic features like
ecDNA? Is it through epigenetic features?
Is it through tumor microenvironmental interactions?
And the idea is that we can decorate the same trees with all of these potential
explanatory features and through this cross-correlation explain how much
of the heritability is driven by each one of those factors.
Now, switching to the second part of the talk, using the genome as a residual
disease sensor, and
MaxIntroduced us to this problem, but just
to reiterate how unusual it is in what we do in oncology compared to
other areas of medicine. So take the example of adjuvant chemotherapy,
and this is a real example we can take.
We treat often 100 patients to benefit three
or four or five. There are many patients who actually
were cured by surgery, and yet we're treating them with probably the worst thing
that a doctor can give a patient in terms of cost and toxicity.
And there are other patients that have residual disease, that have
potential lethal disease, and do not benefit from this costly and
toxic therapy, and potentially need urgently something else.
And this is true in the adjuvant setting, but it's also true more broadly
across the continuum of clinical cancer
care. And we started working on this problem 10 years when I
started the lab in New York City.
We were excited about circulating tumor DNA, this idea that you have
DNA in the blood that can be used to identify residual disease.
And the paradigm then, and potentially still mostly now in industry and
academia, was to do deep targeted sequencing.
The idea is that circulating tumor DNA in the plasma is very sparse,
so we need to sequence at informative loci, let's say the KRAS locus,
very, very deeply, such that we can capture, let's say, one fragment
out of a million.
Now, we realized as we started to
look at these data, that there was an elephant in the room that wasn't as
recognized then, but I think is much more recognized today, that
when we draw a tube of blood from a patient, there's only so much
DNA in it. And in fact, there are only a few thousand genomic
equivalents. So in theory, we can sequence a million X that
KRAS locus, but in practice, we're hitting our head against the ceiling, the
number of actual physical fragments.
So then we thought, how can we overcome this limitation?
And we thought that breadth could potentially supplant depth.
Instead of doing target sequencing, we can aggregate signal
across the entire genome.
So statistically speaking, looking at one spot in the genome 10,000
times should be equivalent to looking across 10,000 spots in the genome
much more shallowly. But from the detection perspective,
this results in a radical, dramatic change.
Whereas with a single locus, let's say digital drop with PCR, where you
see a precipitous drop in sensitivity when we go below,
let's say 1 to 1,000. That's the ceiling that I was talking about, the number of
genomic equivalents. But when we are tracking 10,000 mutations across the
genome, even with a modest sequencing effort of 30 or 50x, we can
engage very much lower
concentration of ctDNA.
And moreover, we provide a quantitative metric.
Doctors, clinicians, patients need not only to know if there is residual
disease or not, but also is it coming up? Is it coming down?
We need a quantitative metric to help guide therapy.
So how can we do better? One thing we have done is to leverage
artificial intelligence to increase signal and decrease
noise. Remember, there are only a few somatic mutations because of the sparsity of
ctDNA, and they're
within a sea of
sequencing errors and other artifacts that are related to the damage to the actual
DNA molecules. And Adam Wittman, who's currently faculty at MSK,
tackled this by understanding that there are lots of different features that
distinguish true somatic mutations from
sequencing artifact and damage to the DNA, the particular
mutational signature, where in the genome, the fragment length, and so on,
and they could be best integrated using modern deep learning
architectures. Now, one feature that's important to remember
is that these deep learning architectures are very data hungry.
They need training sets that involve lots and lots of observation.
And this can be done because our classifier is classifying
mutations at the level of the individual DNA fragment.
It goes fragment by fragment and asks the question: Is the variant we're
seeing an actual somatic mutation, or is it some kind of
artifact or error?
So we validated this together with
Claus Andersen from Aarhus. This is with digital drop of PCR,
and we have similar results with Signatera.
And what you can see is above 1 to 1,000, 1 to 10,000,
there is a good matchup between our results and the targeted approach.
But as we go below that level, the targeted approaches start to
struggle, again, because of that limitation
on the number of genomic equivalents.
What it allows us to do is to measure circulating tumor DNA at
landmark time points after surgery or after adjuvant
chemotherapy and predict outcome even more than two years
before it occurs.
Now, I mentioned how we can use artificial intelligence to
increase signal and decrease noise, but we can also use
molecular ways to do so.
So one of the things that happened in the last couple of years was a seismic shift
in the sequencing market. For many years, the cost of sequencing has
stagnated,
largely from commercial reasons, but in the last couple of years, we've seen a
massive drop in the cost, almost an order of magnitude.
Alex Zhang, who's now faculty in Montreal, reasons that we can
use this extra capacity to
perform what's called duplex sequencing.
So in duplex sequencing, those errors that are caused by DNA
damage can be distinguished from true somatic mutations
because they're not found on the complementary strand.
We barcode each one of the strands and sequence them
separately, but through finding complementary strands, we
can ask, is it a true somatic mutation, meaning the bases on both
strands are complementary, or is it some kind of damage to the DNA
where we would find that they're non-complementary?What this allows us to do is to
really get very clean mutational profiles.
This is how a melanoma tumor looks like with a strong UV
signature. This is how the whole genome looks like without this duplex.
You see that there's very little similarity.
That's because most of the variants we're seeing are all sorts
of artifacts and errors. But when we apply the duplex
correction, you see that it becomes almost a perfect mirror of what we
expect, suggesting that now most of the mutations are actually
true somatic variants.
Now, one of the challenges of duplex sequencing is that it's very sequencing
greedy.
We need to sequence 100X, and we get at the end of the day,
maybe one or two X. And that's because what we do is we barcode
both of the strands, but then denature the DNA molecule, put them in a
big pool with billions of different fragments, and then hope that
after the sequencing procedure, we can pair them back together.
So together with colleagues at Ultima, we came up with a different
solution, and that leverages the Ultima sequencer ability to
sequence each individual fragment on an emulsion bead.
What it allows you to do is to load onto the sequencer directly
a double-stranded molecule, so that instead of relying on
catching them back after the sequencing, they stick
together throughout the sequencing procedure.
So we could get accuracy that's very similar to duplex,
but more than an order of magnitude higher efficiency.
What it means is that essentially you can do a regular, cheap whole
genome sequencing and have a quality of a duplex
genome.
So how does it work? In the tumor-informed setting, we identify all the somatic
mutations that are found in the tumor and then use it as a fingerprint and try
to detect those mutations in the plasma.
And you can see here in lung cancer that we are able, just with
a 30X whole genome, to
have sensitivity in the parts per million range.
We also thought, "What happens a few years from now when sequencing cost
drops even further?" We can sequence a 300X, and we can go to
below the parts per million range, which I think is very exciting.
Jonathan Duan from Charlie Swanton's group validated it on the TRACERx
cohort, and we compared it to Personalis, which is perhaps
the most advanced
patient-specific targeted panel using 800 SNVs and
a personalized hybrid capture panel.
And you can see that the performance is largely similar, as
is the ability to predict the future outcome.
Because the profiles are so clean, because the mutations are so
distinct now, we can again try to see if we can just
use the plasma to try and find the mutational signature of the tumor.
And this was done with Bishoy Faltas from Cornell, and we looked for the APOBEC
signature that we heard today that is very frequently seen in bladder
cancer. And in fact, even if we don't have the matched tumor, which is
sometimes limiting in clinical scenarios, we can use the APOBEC
signature as our detection signal.
We did a similar exercise in lung cancer, this time
using the tobacco signature as a detection signal, again, in the absence
of a matched tumor.
So why is this so exciting?
Just to give you a clinical example. Here, this is from Adam's work.
You can see here
two patients that one of them had
a clear benefit from immunotherapy, this is a melanoma, and
another patient where there was limited benefit.
And we can tell this without imaging, even after three weeks.
But what we noticed is that there are some individuals that had a decrease in the
circulating tumor DNA early and yet had adverse
outcome, early recurrence, and we wondered why.
And we went back to the patient records, and we observed that those
patients that had a good response initially were
treated often with steroids. And we know that in immunotherapy, many
times there's immune-related adverse effects, and oncologists
give steroids to these patients to try and treat those immune effects.
But these steroids are reversing the course of the
disease, are reversing the therapeutic impact of immunotherapy.
And I think that this type of information given to clinicians and to patients
could help us all optimize how we treat patients.
In this example, I'm showing you how we're treating with a
T-cell-directed therapy but also provide steroids that are
eliminating those very same T cells.
So just to summarize, I'm really excited about turning the cancer
genome from a static descriptor into a dynamic clinical
sensor.
It has favorable cost and scalability for MRD.
The cost of a 30X whole genome today is just $80, and
scalability is because we don't need patient-specific
reagents. We don't need complex workflows, centralized lab.
Anyone can do this anywhere across the globe.
Whole genome sequencing is the easiest library to make.
There's opportunity to integrate additional features.
I didn't have time to go over it today,
but our work has shown that we can detect signals of aneuploidy, copy number
variation, fragmentomics, or changes in fragment length,
and epigenetic features. And whole genome sequencing in this era
of AI serves as a learning system. Every
whole genome that we sequence, we can learn and optimize the algorithms for the
next one, which we can't do with those patient-specific panels that although
are providing really useful information today, cannot be
reinterrogated in the future. And as I showed you, the use
of machine learning and this high data
intense work can also pave the path to
plasma-only detection as well.
So just to summarize, in closing,
I'm excited about harnessing the cancer genome
to expose the hidden lives of cancer cells.
And these seem like two different problems, butIn
some ways, they are a shared ambition.
In both of those scenarios, we are trying to
extract weak but structured information
from complex mixtures. In one hand, we're looking at the genome to
read the history of the tumor,
understand its genetic and phenotypic evolution, and in the
other, we're using the genome as a sensor to read out residual disease
and predict future outcome.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Landau.
Our fourth speaker of the session is Dr.
Jeannie Tee. She is a professor at the Peter MacCallum Cancer Center
and also gets the prize for having come the longest way to be here today.
Her talk is titled "MRD Directed Treatment Strategies in
Colorectal Cancer."
Good afternoon.
Firstly, I want to thank the program committee and chairs for this
kind invitation to speak today. It is truly a privilege to
be here.
Now, we've heard three outstanding talks
about how cancer cells persist and
evolve.
As a clinician, I find what is most compelling about
MRD is where this biology is now
clinically actionable. So
the focus on my talk today will be on how MRDs
are already influencing clinical decision making,
and also how it's starting to reshape the way we design clinical
trials and think about regulatory endpoints.
Here are my disclosures.
To start with,
I want to describe a
simple observation.
That is that cure in solid tumor and colorectal
cancer is fundamentally a function of disease
burden.
And we've learned from adjuvant trial
data, the seminal work back in 1990s and
2004,
that about 30% of patients with
micrometastatic disease, is a patient who
supposedly had their tumor resected,
micrometastatic disease, are cured by systemic
chemotherapy.
Whilst when the disease burden is high and clinically
detectable in imaging, that cure rate collapse to near
zero.
And this phenomenon is not unique to colorectal cancer.
We see it as in other solid tumor types as well as
hematological condition, as well as using
immunotherapy and CAR T-cell therapy.
And we consistently see the outcomes are better when the
disease burden is low. So if we want to cure more
cancers, we need to treat early.
But why have we not made progress, particularly in colorectal
cancer, since oxaliplatin-based doublet chemotherapy became
standard of care over two decades ago?
We've had eight negative phase three trials, none of
which have improved upon FOLFOX or CAPOX
chemotherapy.
And more recently, we have some promising signal from a
very biomarker-selected group of patients, but
overall, the gain has still been very modest.
So in my mind, I would argue that there are three key challenges that
have held us back.
The first is suboptimal patient selection, because most of the
patients we treat in the adjuvant setting don't actually have residual
disease, and we're likely diluting a potential
efficacy signal.
Second is no real-time markers of treatment
efficacy, meaning that we'll need to follow the patient for a
long time, many years, to get their clinical
efficacy signal.
And finally, our current trial paradigms is really too
slow for the rapidly evolving therapies, which you'll be
hearing during this meeting and other meetings.
Now, here's the human costs of our current approach,
which Dr. Landau has alluded to earlier.
If I use pathology stage alone to select patient for
adjuvant chemotherapy,
for example, if I treat 100 stage two colon cancer patients,
just with pathological staging alone, only four
patient will benefit from treatment, whilst the other 96
will receive unnecessary chemotherapy and its toxicity
because majority of them are either cured, in blue there,
or have chemo-resistant disease, in red.
Now, contrast this to a ctDNA-guided MRD
adjuvant therapy
approach.
Let's say if a ctDNA assay
can identify 15 out of these 100
patients with residual disease, including
those four in green who has chemosensitive disease,
and we only treat those 15 patients, we are still curing the four
patients,
but we are reducing the number to treat from 25 down
to four
and sparing 85 patients from unnecessary
overtreatment.
There's a second reason why enrichment matters, and that's trial
efficiency.
Currently, if we conduct trial in a unselected
patient population, all comers populationTypically,
the absolute benefit in RFS is around 5%, and that will
require a sample size over 2,000 with
sufficient power to detect this effect.
And let's say we now enrich the trial population to
MRD positive patient,
those who genuinely have residual disease.
That effect size now increased to 20%, and all of a
sudden, our sample size requirement drops by
around 15-fold to around 150,
dramatically improving trial efficiency.
Now, just to prove that I didn't just hallucinate and make that up, I'm
going to show you some real example.
So in colorectal cancer, the SWOG 80702
study was a large, randomized adjuvant trial
involving about 2,500 patient, testing the
benefit of adjuvant celecoxib in combination with
folfox chemotherapy in all comers.
Now, as you can see from the time to event recurrence-free survival curve at the
bottom there, there's a trend for a benefit, but overall,
the study was negative.
And the investigator had the foresight of collecting some post-op plasma
DNA.
And when the outcome was stratified by ctDNA, you can see
here very clearly that only the ctDNA positive group of
patient benefited from celecoxib, but not the
ctDNA negative patient, supporting the fact that
signal may be diluted in an all-comer trial,
whilst there's actually hidden
benefit in the right population.
Now, the story from bladder cancer, which I'm sure all of you will be aware
of,
is arguably the most compelling evidence to date on
how ctDNA or MRD enrichment can
enable a successful trial.
So IMvigo-010 was overall a negative study,
testing adjuvant atezo versus observation in bladder
cancer
without selecting for ctDNA status.
But exploratory analysis, as you can see here, showed that only, again, only
ctDNA positive patient benefited from treatment and not a negative
one. And that led to the IMvigo-011 randomized
study. This is the first
prospective ctDNA-enriched
randomized trial where they enrolled 250 patients
who are ctDNA positive within 12
months of cystectomy.
And the results of this randomized trial confirmed
and validated the finding in the exploratory analysis in
that adjuvant atezo did benefit the ctDNA
positive patients.
Now, I want to pivot back to colorectal cancer and remind ourselves
of the strong prognostic impact of post-op ctDNA,
in this setting, across all different stages and different
setting, and be it
from observational studies such as this that we've done in Australia
and in Japan, the Galaxy study in the US, real-world bespoke
study, or in randomized trial in the bottom two panel
there,
using different type of assay, academic, commercial, tumor-informed, or
tumor-naive. Think the message is consistent.
If ctDNA ever becomes detectable after treatment,
recurrence is a near certainty.
Now, and more importantly, ctDNA is not only
prognostic. Observational studies suggest that it could also be
predictive of adjuvant chemotherapy benefit.
As you can see here, in those with a ctDNA negative
disease, they do very well regardless of
chemotherapy. However, we can see that in
ctDNA positive patient, they derive some benefit
from adjuvant chemotherapy.
Now with these findings,
I think there are three different
landmark windows where MRD can add clinical
value. The most obvious one is in the post-op
setting, telling us who will need further adjuvant
chemotherapy after their curative intent
surgery or other therapy modalities such as chemoradiation.
High-risk ctDNA positive patients should receive some form of treatment,
whereas the low-risk ctDNA negative patient can
potentially safely avoid treatment.
The second window, if they do have adjuvant chemotherapy, is at the
end of treatment landmark where we can use ctDNA
clearance to give us an indication if the adjuvant treatment has
eradicated the residual disease.
And here, I think there's a real opportunity to flag patients
who have not cleared their residual diseases,
that could need further therapy.
And finally, in the surveillance window, to use ctDNA to
detect recurrence earlier than our current surveillance strategy,
potentially introducing more or earlier
intervention to further cure oligometastatic disease.
Now, in my talk, I will not elaborate further on surveillance given the interest of
time, and also that the randomized evidence in this
setting are still maturing.
So how do we prove clinical value
of MRD? I think there are broadly two approaches to MRD-directed
trial design. The first is the strategy design called testing the
test. And here we ask, "Is my patient better
off if I use the test to guide treatment decision?"
And this approach truly directly tests the clinical
utility of the test and is what regulator usually
needs before a test enter into routine
practice.The second is the treatment design or
testing the treatment. And here we use ctDNA
testing to identify the population that we would test a
drug on. So once you identify the population, patients are then
randomized to a drug versus control.
And this design directly tested drug efficacy in an
MRD-defined subgroup of patients.
Now, both these design are important, but they do address
very different questions, and the right choice will ultimately
depend on the question you want to answer.
Now, the first randomized prospective trial
using this strategy design is the DYNAMIC trial.
Given the modest impact and benefit of adjuvant chemotherapy in
stage II disease, this trial
essentially asked the question: Can we safely spare the
majority of stage II colon cancer patients from
chemotherapy if their ctDNA tells us they don't need
it?
So here's the trial design. Four hundred and fifty-five stage II
colon cancer patients were recruited from
23 Australian centers and randomized to ctDNA guided
management or standard management.
In the standard management arm, adjuvant treatment decisions were based on
conventional criteria. In the ctDNA guided arm,
those with a positive test at either week four or seven,
noted there's two serial samples being taken, receive adjuvant
chemotherapy, whilst those with a negative test at both time
points were observed.
The primary endpoint was two-year recurrence-free survival with a non-inferiority
margin of 8.5%. And importantly, the
ctDNA testing was done centrally in an academic center at
Ludwig Center at Hopkins using a targeted colorectal
panel.
So looking at the treatment delivery, so indeed, using
ctDNA guided management, the use
of chemotherapy was reduced by half from 28% in the
standard management arm to 15% in the ctDNA
guided arm.
And cost impact analysis also showed that this approach, a
tumor-informed ctDNA guided approach, are cost savings.
And importantly, despite reducing the use of
chemotherapy by half, the outcome, the
five-year recurrence-free survival, are almost identical between the
two groups, with a five-year recurrence-free survival of
88.3% and
87.2%.
And this provides the first prospective randomized
evidence that using ctDNA to guide treatment
can
help us safely deescalate therapy.
Now,
the biology of ctDNA goes beyond positive and
negative. What you can see here is that we stratify the
overall survival by post-op ctDNA status, and those
with a ctDNA negative disease do extremely well despite being
observed only with a five-year overall survival of
95%. However, the ctDNA positive patient,
despite adjuvant chemotherapy, they don't do as well with
a survival of 85.6%.
Now, what is even more intriguing, we're starting to see that
amongst the ctDNA positive patient, that molecular
burden matters. So when we stratify a patient by the
molecular burden defined here as tumor-derived mutant molecules per ml,
those above the median, more than 0.38,
do a lot worse than patient with low molecular
burden below the median.
So I think this suggests that ctDNA positive patients are quite
heterogeneous. They're not all the same and potentially could be further
stratified by molecular burden, which may help us as clinicians
decide if they should receive standard adjuvant
chemotherapy or may need more intensive treatment.
Now, can we apply the same principle to stage III colon cancer?
So the DYNAMIC 3 study really was designed to address this.
So in stage III colon cancer, unlike stage II, the benefit
of three to six months of oxaliplatin adjuvant chemotherapy
is very well established. However, for the
individual patient, the absolute gain remains uncertain, and we
do see that the benefit does vary across different substages within
stage III. And importantly, about 30% of patients
still recurred despite
three to six months of doublet chemotherapy.
So DYNAMIC 3 randomized stage III colon cancer
patient
to ctDNA-informed management again and standard
management. And in the standard of care arm, the ctDNA
results were blinded. The clinicians were blinded to the
results.
Again, we used a tumor-informed analysis, but only one time point
at week five to six were used to guide management.
In the negative group, clinician deescalated the treatment
intensity,
and in the positive group, the treatment were escalated,
including using triplet chemotherapy for VOXERI.
Now, the study was designed really to address two questions.
Can we safely deescalate treatment adjuvant chemotherapy in
ctDNA negative patients compared to standard of care management?
And in the positive group, does treatment escalation improve
recurrence-free survival?
So we randomized over 1,000 patients across 66 hospitals,
across three countries, in Australia, New Zealand, and
Canada.And as expected, about 73%
of patients returned as ctDNA negative results,
and 27 ctDNA positive, and they were very
balanced across the two arms.
So let's look at the ctDNA negative de-escalation
cohort. Treatment de-escalation
expectedly reduced the intensity of chemotherapies
quite substantially, particularly with the oxaliplatin use from
89% down to 35%, and
consequentially, we reduce high-grade
toxicity as well as
treatment-related hospitalization.
And at three years, the recurrence-free survival with
88% with standard management and
85.3% with ctDNA guidance,
with an absolute difference of -2.8%.
Now, you see there that the lower bound of the confidence
interval of -8 just misses our pre-specified
non-inferiority margin of -7.5%.
So obviously, this is not what the results we've hoped for, but
it does highlight the limitation of older
earlier assay in safely guiding
de-escalation of treatment, as well as
potentially the lack of serial sampling in our study design.
Now, acknowledging the limitation of this earlier assay, we then looked
at some of the end of treatment samples from our stage II colon
cancer study,
and testing our earlier colorectal targeted
panel,
and compare them with whole exome sequencing guided
personalized assay. And you can see that the sensitivity improved
dramatically. So with the older targeted panel, we
tracked an average of three variants per patients
and with a sensitivity of 57% at the end of treatment time
point. But using the whole exome sequencing
guided personalized approach, we tracked an average of
29 variants and improving sensitivity to
85.5%.
Now, I want to take this opportunity to really acknowledge
the three talented PhD student from the Bert
Vogelstein's lab at the Hopkins, who I've had the opportunity
and privilege to work with over the past decade.
Have really driven the assay evolution,
improving along with many others in the field, improving
the sensitivity of MRD assay from
one in 100,000 now to the current assay,
often close to one in 10 million.
Now let's turn to the DYNAMIC 3 ctDNA
high-risk positive cohort.
So we have quite aggressively
escalated chemotherapy in a ctDNA-guided
arm with about half the patient receiving
triplet folfoxiri chemotherapy, and the other half having six
months of doublet chemotherapy, whereas in the standard arm,
only half the patient received six months of oxali doublet
and no patient received folfoxiri.
Now, disappointingly, despite this aggressive treatment
escalation,
we did not demonstrate a superiority in their
outcome
in ctDNA positive patient.
And like stage two disease, we saw that we could further
stratify the patient's outcome dramatically
using a molecular burn with a three-year recurrence-free
survival of 23% in patient with the highest
quartile of molecular burn compared to 77%
in patient with the lowest quartile of molecular burn.
I think taken together, what this suggests is that
chemotherapy alone may not be sufficient in
ctDNA positive disease, particularly in those with
high
ctDNA molecular burn,
either because the disease burn is too high, there's too much heterogeneity,
and really using the more of the same mechanism
of drug may not be sufficient to overcome it.
Now when we look at ctDNA clearance
in the DYNAMIC 3 study, we use a whole genome sequencing
approach, tracking up to 96 variants,
and we showed that 60% of patient managed to clear
their ctDNA at the end of treatment, and
40% had ctDNA persistence. More
importantly, we found that the clearance
or lack of clearance at the end of treatment could
discriminate the outcome for these patients quite dramatically.
With those with persistent
MRD having a three-year recurrence-free survival of only
14%, and whereas the negative patient had a
three-year RFS of 79%. I think there's
two implications with this finding.
First is that those with persistent MRD disease really
need something else.
And the second implication is that ctDNA clearance appears
to be very promising as a potential surrogate marker of
treatment efficacy,
and potentially for regulatory approval in the future.
Now, we know that ctDNA positive patient after adjuvant
treatment is extremely high risk. What can we do with them?
I think the field's moving quite rapidly in this area, and this
slide is deliberately busy, really just to showcase the
breadth of mechanism that's currently being tried in this
setting, going from cytotoxic re-challenge
to personalized mRNA vaccine to
novel immunotherapy combinationADC
and importantly, several platform trial
investigating multiple strategies at the
same time more efficiently.
I'm really looking forward to seeing the results of some of the study.
But I really want to briefly highlight our
ALTTEAR study, which is the first study that has now had mature
outcome data that has been reported at AACR last year,
and also subsequently with updated data at ESMO GI.
So ALTTEAR really was designed to
demonstrate that Longsurf or
TAS-102, a cytotoxic can improve
recurrence-free survival in patients who remain ctDNA
positive after curative resection or standard peri-op treatment.
Now I can see here that
although there's initial gap in the disease-free survival
curve, the disease-free survival rate by 18
months has all come together and very similar between the two groups, suggesting
that treatment is simply delaying recurrence but not curing patients.
And the ctDNA clearance data similarly reflect the lack of efficacy
with no significant difference between the two group.
Clearance of 17% in the intervention and
12% in the placebo group. And this study, although negative, I
think has demonstrated the strategy is feasible,
but perhaps cytotoxic may not be the way forward as we've seen with
our DYNAMIC 3 study.
I want to now look towards the future.
I think the next challenge
for a researcher in the solid
tumor MRD field to tackle is
really think about using ctDNA not only
just for patient selection but also as
a regulatory endpoint to accelerate drug
approval.
Now the myeloma field has
very successfully obtained FDA
support to enable MRD negativity as
a endpoint for accelerated drug
approval through a methodical
multi-step process.
They have a standardized endpoint.
They have a locked, robust assay with a defined minimum
threshold of sensitivity of 10 minus five.
They have very strong trial level meta-analysis or
meta-analytic data
involving 20 randomized phase three studies and
over 12,000 patients linking treatment impact
on MRD to progression-free survival.
Now that we have the recipe,
I think in the solid tumor field, researcher need to now
gather all the ingredients
to make this possible. We need a well-defined molecular endpoint, which I
think will be durable ctDNA clearance, fit for
purpose assay that are reproducible.
We need to demonstrate that ctDNA is not only
prognostic, but it is also
drug responsive, such as what I've demonstrated in DYNAMIC 3, drug responsive to
chemotherapy.
And we ultimately need many randomized trial
data with long follow-up that is validated at the trial
level
within a meta-analysis which will require, I think,
coordinated global effort. And we'll get there.
I think the
regulatory path for solid tumor is really opening up.
The FDA have issued the draft guidance
recently on defining the potential three
roles of ctDNA MRD, the first being that
it can be used to enrich patients to enroll onto a clinical trial
to explore new therapy. A second, as a measure
of drug activity, particularly in early phase trial, to get an
early
signal of activity so that prioritization
can be provided on which drug to move forward to a randomized
phase three study.
As for ctDNA as an early endpoint, although it
is promising,
it is not currently validated.
FDA has explicitly recommended that quantitative
ctDNA analysis be done at multiple time points and
also recommended
prospective randomized trials with long-term outcomes
to be collected
and conducted. So shown here are the global MRD efforts in
colorectal cancer, with many trials ongoing
and being conducted with different assays, with different strategies
at different regions. And hopefully, all these trial data
will contribute towards a data set that will eventually
validate ctDNA as an endpoint in
colorectal cancer, and similarly could be done in other solid tumor.
And ACCENT, CIRCULATE, and REVERSE Early
Recurrence are two coordinated international effort
trying to make this
happen.
So I just want to bring it all together.
ctDNA, I think is no longer a prognostic marker
but is ready for clinical use.
DYNAMIC 2 study has really
established the first evidence that we can use ctDNA to guide safety
escalation by halving chemotherapy used and not
compromising our five-year outcome.
We saw in stage three disease that we're approaching
non-inferiorityAnd maybe with newer
generation assay and serial monitoring, we'll likely get there.
The key unmet need in this field, I think, is treatment
escalation for ctDNA-positive disease.
Although we're still awaiting more definitive data with triplet
chemotherapy used in ctDNA-positive patients from the circulate North
American study, the evidence to date suggests that cytotoxic
intensification alone may not be sufficient to overcome
the bad prognosis for this patient.
And we're now starting to see different mechanisms being explored in the
post-adjuvant setting.
In terms of trial design, we know the MRD can enrich patients
for clinical trial, and that will reduce the sample size and improve trial
efficiency.
And looking to the future in terms of using clearance as a
regulatory endpoint, we now have the
model from myeloma to follow. We have FDA
guidance. We also have many randomized trials being conducted,
and the infrastructure now that pool the data set all together,
and are hopeful that in 10, 15 years time, we will
have the same outcome as our myeloma colleagues.
So I just want to acknowledge, I think all this work is not possible
without extraordinary team
putting effort together. The sponsor of the trials
that I run,
Walter Leyser Hall and the GI Cancer Trials group from Australia,
the coordinating team at Walter Leyser Hall, the
molecular expertise from my long-term collaborators, both
Vogelstein, Nick Papadopoulos, and Ken Kinzler at the Ludwig
Center, Johns Hopkins, obviously, all the funding support, and
importantly, the patients who have contributed their time and effort
to our observational study, as well as all the randomized trial.
So thank you for your attention.
Thank you, Dr. Te.
All right. In the last few minutes, I will summarize
the highlights of what we have seen and look to the future.
So,
getting back to this framework for this session that there's two dominant types of
MRD in solid tumors, the first being MRD after systemic therapy in
advanced disease when patients have deep responses.
We learned that there's really two main causes that have been identified of this
type of resistance of minimal residual disease.
The first is somatic alterations, resistance mutations, which
themselves can be classified into two groups.
One are early mutations that arise quickly after starting therapy.
These are driven by preexisting mutation, preexisting mutant
clones that are already there. The second is the late
emerging resistance mutations, and these, as Dr.
Hoda showed us, are due to adaptive mutagenic mechanisms such
as those driven by the APOBEC family of enzymes that allow the persister cells
to continue to accumulate mutations as they are
being treated with the targeted agents to eventually
select for a mutation that gives rise to resistance.
The second dominant type of resistance
mechanism in this MRD in advanced disease
is plasticity, cellular plasticity, and this is independent of
somatic mutations. This is driven by expression changes and
epigenetic changes that aren't due to mutations.
And interestingly, as we heard, this cellular plasticity can be
promoted by interaction of the tumor cells with the microenvironment.
For example, the tumor-associated fibroblasts that can induce
the keratin 17-positive states in the lung cancer examples we
saw.
And as Dr. Lander showed us, even though
plasticity is not a somatic mutation-based mechanism, it is still
heritable. These cells, when they divide and give rise to their daughter
cells, those daughter cells often maintain, or usually maintain
the new cell state and cell lineage.
And so therefore, once it's acquired, it is as if it's
largely fixed in the population.
So how then could we think about treating this type of
resistance? And this is a glass half full and glass half empty story,
where the glass half full part is that we already actually have some clinical
approaches that we can use on patients today that can treat
these persister cells. And I am referring to the use of
things like chemotherapy together with targeted agents.
So here, the example for the FLORA2 trial was a trial in advanced metastatic
EGFR mutant non-small cell, where patients were treated with an EGFR TKI plus
chemotherapy. And the addition of chemotherapy led to a survival
advantage, suggesting that if one hits the cells from the
get-go with a second treatment that has a different set of
resistance mechanisms, one can suppress, at least for some time,
this persister state, and that's not limited to systemic therapy.
Actually, the Northstar trial from MD Anderson showed us that
in the same setting, instead of using chemo, if one uses radiotherapy
to target the visible lesions to try to ablate those, that
can lead to similar survival benefit.
So we do have some approaches. The glass half empty part, though, is that those
curves are not what we want them to be.
We need to develop better treatments that can get more of the
patients to live much longer. And so what are the future approaches?
Well, we heard about one very novel one today, targeting changes in cellular
volume
by Dr. Marin.
That's a very intriguing potential novel approach.
But many others have been proposed in this field.
We heard about ferroptosis because these cells are dependent on iron metabolism,
more sensitive to ferroptosis. One could try to prevent or reverse
lineage plasticity by interfering with the signaling from the stroma to these
cells. One could imagine immune-based therapies that target antigens if one could
identify antigens that are specific to the persister cells.
And also others have proposed using adaptive or intermittent
therapy where one treats tumors for a certain amount of time but then
relaxes treatment to allow the cells to start proliferating again, and then
you start treatment again.What about the second type of
MRD? The MRD we see in early-stage disease after local therapy like
surgery, and again, these are the patients where the resistance is driven by the
microscopic metastases that have not yet experienced treatment.
And here, really this field has been revolutionized, as we heard from Dr.
Lan on Dr. T, by the advent of circulating tumor DNA assays that have been
shown across solid tumor types to be able to detect this type of MRD.
Importantly, in this field, the dominant approach and the preferred
approach is the tumor-informed approach both Dr.
Lan and T told us about, where one sequences the tumor, identifies
mutations, and then tracks them in plasma samples subsequently.
There's multiple ways to do that, personalized assays, whole genome assays.
Exactly how one does it is not so important.
What matters is how sensitive that approach is.
You want the most sensitive approach possible.
And importantly, these ctDNA MRD assays are already in the
clinic. In the US, we have insurance reimbursement for multiple
ctDNA MRD assays for a variety of tumor types, including colon, breast,
lung, and others. And so these are tests that are being run on patients.
We see them in our clinic every week.
Now, what can we do with these type of assays? As Dr.
T outlined, there's two main things. One is escalation.
Take the ctDNA positive patients, treat them with something active, and get them
to try to have better outcomes to cure more of those patients.
And that was shown to work in the IMvigor-011 trial
in muscle-invasive bladder cancer, where immunotherapy was able to
improve outcomes in those patients.
I think an important lesson from the colon stage III data Dr.
T showed us is that you don't just need a good test, you also need a good
treatment. These are studies that will only work if you have the right test and the
right treatment in this setting.
And the second approach is de-escalation, where we can try to stop
over-treating patients, which currently we do a lot in the adjuvant
space by de-escalating treatment for the ctDNA
MRD negatives. So what are the next steps in this part of the
MRD field? Well, the first is the field is moving and should continue to move
to using these ultra-sensitive ctDNA MRD assays that we heard about that are up to
100 times more sensitive than the first-generation assays, can get us down into the
or below the parts per million range, and will allow us to detect the majority
of patients who are ultimately going to develop recurrence, which will make the
trials more feasible and also make de-escalation strategies
safer. The second is we do still need to demonstrate clinical utility.
We need many more interventional trials that prove that intervening based on
ctDNA MRD can improve outcomes. Without that, insurance will not
reimburse treatments based on MRD, and that
is one of the key challenges we currently face clinically.
And then lastly, I agree with Dr. T that MRD should
be further developed as an endpoint in the adjuvant setting so
that in the future we could hopefully
drive accelerated drug approvals based on ctDNA MRD clearance
rather than waiting years as we currently have to in adjuvant
drug approval trials. And to do that, we all have to work together.
That means industry, academia, regulators, we have to work together to get
these assays, get the data we need to
prove that these can be robust surrogate endpoints and can allow us
to get life-saving drugs to patients faster.
So with that, I want to thank you for attending this plenary session.
I want to thank the speakers for their excellent talks and for sharing unpublished
data, and I hope you have a great rest of your meeting. Thank you.